all right we have larry uh larry rob
amanda's father
and we have lima who has a plan in how
to help uh
amanda welcome lima welcome uh larry
hello larry uh you haven't even seen any
of the videos i've shot
of amanda right no because after hearing
them
hearing about them i figured well i had
seen the day-to-day the slide show so
i'm living it
so i i've not watched the videos no i i
recommend you don't first off uh
let me let me clarify something amanda
said some things in her first
interview with me um about you that
uh your oldest daughter wanted me to
clarify and
make sure everyone understood they were
not true amanda says some crazy things
when she comes in here
and she says i'm about everybody so it's
not just you she said the same thing
about many many people
so whatever amanda said about her father
in that first video it's a bunch of
nonsense
so i just wanted to say that so larry uh
tell me a little bit about your life uh
you have how many children i have four
children i have three girls and one boy
and a man is your youngest
amanda is my youngest child and tell me
about your life you were
a war veteran yes i went into the air
force i had
some scholarships offered in out of high
school but i chose to do a university
and it was quite expensive so i chose
the air force because i wanted to travel
so after choosing that then all sorts of
opportunities opened up
i was kind of a young guy having fun
going around
had some good deployments the air force
was very good to me
i did 11 and a half years there so
travel and all of that sort of fulfilled
those young man
intuitions of something to do that was
beyond me
so that was an experience i'll never
never forget and i'm still having
benefits from it 45 years later that's
great
so the issues with amanda have been
going on for about how long
since september of 2016. how did it
start
she was in college right yes she and i
she was at the
csun cal state northridge she had had a
successful elementary in high school
she went to a chartered high school
because as a single parent i said well
let me just do whatever i can to fill in
the blank you know give her that extra
edge for you know her trajectory so
trajectory so
she did very very well in high school
and
uh she went to csun she was doing very
well she was a
critical thinker a writer so she was
doing well in her classes
but then she started to not show up when
i would visit her during the mid-week
and take her groceries i was at
the university myself she challenged me
so i said okay i went to dominguez
so that's why i was at the university
because she challenged me
so i went to get a degree in sociology
at that time but i was going up there
you know as a parent
twice a week and she would disappear and
then she started to tell me
that she was being surveilled and i said
oh no i'm thinking
from my military days i said they don't
even have the resources to keep up with
you amanda bear so
that's kind of how this started and then
after a few months of
not seeing her she had established some
new friends that i never met
i had her diagnosed and it was
schizophrenia bipolar
and that was like september of 2016.
and then she started using crack right
she started using crack
that was the following year first when
she started
she started using meth meth scared her
in counseling she said oh my gosh she
looked at me in a way that i knew she
was sincere
she said no meds scared her so she
stopped using meth
after the first six seven eight months
this is from
like looking back on it because at the
time i didn't know she was using drugs
so she was starting to talk about using
crack so she began to use a
used crack in 2017 so she's been using
crack
she had used meth a couple of times
from time to time but she's been using
met i mean
cocaine since then so you and i have
been struggling
with amanda all of this year and some of
last year
um but you've been on the front lines
you're you're her father so you
you've been seeing it from the start but
you've seen
some crazy crazy behavior right i mean
amanda jumps out of cars she gets beaten
up
she walks around through the night the
extreme barefoot
or the extreme first the first year and
a half or so she was down in la
florence western vermont manchester
those areas
so it was quite different for me because
i had to go there just to catch up with
her every day so that's what i did
i put it on my agenda every day i would
go there
so i had not seen her for like three or
four days so i was going to go to
77th and make in my a missing person
i was already she was on on the front
seat of the bus
i got him to the bus i didn't recognize
her
so i went on and sat down
after a stop or so she came back to me
and that
different person that i saw i didn't
know
she was right in front of my face
i felt so bad to this day
i felt so bad because i didn't know her
at first so after i recognized her she
just looked up at me and talked to me
the way she always does
she said dad i said honey what you need
so i said let's go get you some
get you an outfit you know so we did
that
she just wanted to smoke after we got
her outfit
got her shoes and everything she looked
so nice she just said to me
she said i'm thirsty i just want to go
smoke
so it took me a half hour so i walked up
and down manchester with her
so i let her go and smoke
so after that it was day to day and then
she
disappeared on me i did an m.i.a and
they found her she was in the hospital
thank god and i was trying to do a
conservative shift but
i didn't have my ducks in line so she
they released her
so i didn't see her for a while and the
va moved me downtown for section 8
housing
so i didn't see her and i i'm sorry
what was amanda like before this
happened she was just
such a she was almost eloquent to me she
was always yes dad
please dad excuse me dad and i just did
every i kind of relived my childhood so
she got everything she
really wanted we disneyland knott's
berry
all that every year come on dodger
stadium
i think i was more on the hot dogs and i
think you know what i'm saying
she had a good childhood all the
concerts i could get into
and the kid and you know what i'm saying
as long as a parent could take them i
took her
so she had a good childhood she was
having a good time at the university
it's just
a set of friends i never met and i was
almost certain that there was something
in that
relationship that caused her to stray
so after day to day down there i didn't
see her
and i was coming in from church one
sunday and i saw amanda downtown
and she saw me and it was such a relief
and then i had been helping her and i
met mark
and every day it's the challenge it's
different
you know it's just one day she
disappeared for a week
one day she she'd been ran over by a car
she had all her lower and upper teeth
knocked out
she's you know she's just challenging
because of her behavior now she
she only feels like the drug gives her
relief
there's absolutely no way to stop this
girl from getting the drug she wants
no there was one time that i was you
might remember i was trying to take her
to
the clinic to get the prescription for
her schizophrenia
for the medication she needs and uh
as soon as she figured out that i wasn't
taking her to my studio
she backs her legs up and starts she's
going to kick the windows out of my car
to get out of a moving vehicle so i had
to let her out
she'll boat no she'll bolt she'll vote
she's done that yeah
she'll jump out of the car she's been
injured three or four times
because she jumps out of cars she she's
lost her sense of defense and
danger you know danger danger stranger
stranger
she and she never had to engage with
strange people
as a child from daycare to school school
you know what i mean so now it's just
totally different
she's walking around skid row barefoot
sometimes come in no no clothes i've
given her outfit
because that's what i do every day i go
out i get her something we've got to
have some pants mark is giving her
clothes
so she was just no longer in control of
her behavior
she no longer had a sense of okay this
is respectful this is harmful this is
not
good and larry you and i speak on the
phone
very often very often and so many times
we've said
we just need a miracle because nothing
is happening we had to have one
and nothing nothing seems to work the
5150s you know the cops pick her up and
they just let her go right away
and then the difference maker is she
assaulted me because
i was cooperative you know i was glad to
know that i could help her manage her
benefits every month so she don't just
run out in a few days
but after she assaulted me the second
time
i said i have to do something
differently
and then we got a call from mark about
lima and when i heard about someone that
may help us
at the time i had some of the
professionals in the mental
health field here in l.a trying to help
me but all they were doing was
counseling me
amanda was coming in and out of that
door every day creating a problem
one of my friends is a uh he's like the
the head of the
west side of la's uh aana
groups uh all the addiction groups and
he uh
i was telling him about amanda and he
said with people like that there's
nothing you can do
you just have to let them go there's you
can't you can't stop them there's
there's not there's no helping them so
this is a miracle
because i've seen that day to day and i
thank you mark for introducing me to
lima and ivan what a blessing
yeah and then along comes lima so let me
explain what you do
aura your company is is not a rehab
it's a technology that rehabs can use
right
how would you describe what you guys do
so i would say that we're a digital
health company
and um i noticed that from the previous
videos maybe there was a little bit of
confusion but
we are not a hospital we are not a
clinic we work with hospitals and
clinics
and the way i think the best way to
really say how i what i do is that
imagine if cars came without
speedometers
and that you had to guess how fast you
were going
and the statistic was that 90 of
cars don't make it to their destination
and so that's how the treatment centers
are right now so
without measurement how do you know
you're getting better how many treatment
centers has amanda been to
probably seven or eight mm-hmm and so
um everyone that i've spoken to they've
been to
you know way up there like so many so
many treatment centers i've never met
somebody that went
one time and it worked um in 10 percent
of cases
going to treatment is successful 90
percent of the time
those patients don't get to their
destination and we don't measure it so
it's the
so what my company does is we make the
metrics
to measure how a patient is doing
throughout the treatment process that
rehabs will use
exactly so we just make the technology
and we give it to doctors
and therapists and so we're not changing
the way that therapy is given we're
enhancing
therapy so the tools the evidence-based
therapies
they do work and they've been proven to
work
and the where the issue comes in
is that we kind of treat like a lot of
times doctors will
will treat patients with a one size fits
all
so doctors like we talked about in the
first video
are most likely to diagnose you with
what they're most comfortable treating
misdiagnosis is completely rampant with
mental health
and so when it comes to diagnosis
when it comes to treatment most doctors
are going to diagnose and treat you with
what they're most comfortable with
because there's so many overlapping
factors that look they all look very
similar whether you're
bipolar borderline personality
chronically depressed
a lot a lot of them have some of the
same um
you know elements there and so um so
it's very easy to get confused it's
human error
it's not the fault of the doctor it's
the fault of our entire system that we
don't give
mental health professionals tools to
treat patients that's what your company
does that's exactly what we do so we
just offer these tools for health
detection
to help guide the doctor to see
if the type of therapy that they're
giving this patient
is working and to measure the metrics so
that we can say
this patient is not getting to where
they need to be let's try something else
right now i'm fine versus i'm fine
versus
i'm fine those are all different but
like
everyone here is just the words but
we're not really listening to how the
patient is saying it we're not detecting
physically how they're feeling and
we need to we need to work in different
ways to make sure that
you know those 90 percent of like cars
that don't make it to their destination
how do we make sure that across the
board all treatment is the same and that
we use
one uniform measurement so that
medicare treatment center is not lesser
than
a high-end treatment center that's
private pay how do we get
a unified take the highest care of
treatment and scale it across the board
for everyone and have that as
the standard for mental health care so
last week
was very interesting uh that was the
first week that you've been involved in
amanda's
life yes absolutely and larry uh tell me
what happened last week
last week early morning you know you got
to be at court 8 30
8 30. amanda's in jail amanda's she's
she's in jail for an assault assault on
you on me
with a pipe with the pipe so she's
coming to her second
court date and she's expecting release
so
amanda is very provocative she's talking
as she's coming in so amanda's
24 right 24. she's an adult
right yeah she knows that 20 at 21 she
started making that call
and you can't decide that she needs to
go to rehab she's an adult
after the first six months then she took
21 and said no remember i'm an adult
so that was it so early morning 8 30
she's been locked up now for a few weeks
she has a court date
but we have to petition to try to get
conservatorship
and ms lima shows up and petitions her
appearance and her presence
made the difference because i would have
known what to say but the way she
presented it
it was so authentic and they knew that
this is
for real these are sponsored these are
people that's going to help my family
help amanda i can't imagine anyone more
motivated than someone
who's got a startup company and they're
doing something like this on social
media on a high profile social media
channel
you've got everything to lose what
courage what yeah
that's a perfect scenario in my eyes not
only is lima courageous
enough to try to help your child who's
one of the toughest cases
on my on my channel but she's also a
perfect candidate because she's not
going to drop the ball here
there's too many eyes on her no she's
shown that her presence like i said made
the difference
you know being from that military mind
when you show up that means we're ready
to take care of our mission planning
today
so when she said that she was going to
help the family that's something
i will never let go because everybody
understood that not just
amanda but to help amanda will help the
family
and that just that's the difference in
all of our association thus far
and so i've been very lucky that larry
and his family
are will drop everything and just try it
and larry always tells me he's like
anything you need i'll drop
everything and i'll be there anything
yeah because imagine
you know most of the dads down here on
skid row are
they're deadbeat dads they're addicts
they're alcoholics they're they're
they're not there for their kids larry
is the opposite of that and not to
mention
um every single time like yeah larry's a
single father
so there's so so so so many
responsibilities that come with having
someone that has a mental illness that
needs a guardian 24
7 that when you don't hear from her for
an hour
something could have happened and he's
been dealing with all of that
responsibility everything's on his
shoulders and all the worries are on his
shoulders and
there was a day when amanda didn't call
larry from jail
and he was worried about her and i told
him like
larry today's your day to just take a
deep breath and relax
and remember take care of yourself
because amanda needs you
and so um it's just so
incredible to have someone that anyone
would look at amanda and say
oh this girl can't get help i've met
therap like
you know we have a team of therapists
that we're working with
um and i've i've been going through
because we're
we're putting together a team of people
um we have a case manager for amanda
so that person will be there along the
entire route these are well-known
reputable
yeah very very so these are all um
you know when it comes to what you were
mentioning about a 5150 if
um if she were to get picked up and put
under a 5150
which has been done before that's a
three-day hold
the system's so packed so there's so
many people that need help but
it's just so expensive there's not a lot
of staff
and you know the reason that it's
expensive is because these
people need so much attention and so
much care
and for these healthcare providers it's
exhausting everywhere you go
every every day when you go into work
there's a confrontation
this person is yelling at you or they're
upset or
it's a very very stressful job and a lot
of these facilities
um you know they have nurses they have
doctors but
when you go to the lower end facilities
they don't do one-on-one care they have
more patients than doctors
when you go to the higher end facilities
they do a lot more one-on-one and then
they
they just get really up there in price
so
what i was taught just speaking about
regarding the petition
we had i think 800 people sign it
so it is really important and it's not
in the sense of
supporting my company it's in the sense
of supporting some sort of metric
to measure how somebody's doing in
treatment
and again taking that and making it
across the board
larry tell me what happened in court
last week yeah there she was miss lima
she's coming to support us and after she
talks to the d.a
and the public defender we have amanda's
case second
they called her because they know okay
she gets them from she
she requests they come from downstairs
with her because she asked them to bring
her on let's go
so it was just such a blessing to have
that encourage that personal assistance
just
there so amanda came out looking so much
better
she sounds so clear like i said she was
just coming out petitioning now who
makes this decision
do i go home today i have someplace else
to live i don't have to go to my
she had all of her presentation ready to
go so the judge he was very
accommodating but he let her know did
did the the attorney tell you you know
he's gonna yes the attorney admitted
yeah i've told her what to expect
so the next question came she was
telling me
put some money on my books those kind of
things was coming she didn't stop
talking
she stopped talking briefly and then the
judge talked to her he presented
the case and he told her and she's been
in jail for how long
about a month right about a month six
weeks no crack right
no crack talking she'd been taking her
schizophrenia medication yes i talked to
her clinician
a nurse gomez he's very accommodating
she said she's cooperating
eating talking to him taking her meds
every day so the judge talked to her
told her case
and she said to him she's he said to her
would she be up for long-term care
he said it very at the end of his
presentation and she said yes
amanda chose the longer rehab he said
yes
unequivocally she had nothing she just
said yes you guys told me that
i couldn't believe that was her good old
yes i remember that kind of yes you know
she chose the longer rehab as opposed to
a shorter one that's amazing she just
said yes
and to the longer yeah so she had the
option of being released
you know a week ago when i was here and
um
just you know going back and having her
own plan
or their um or we
i'm not going to say the exact date but
um the end of the month
um she could stay in jail and wait until
another court date and so um they told
her that i'm working with her father
to help put in you know put her in a
program and have a long-term plan for
her
and if she would consider to
stay in jail a little bit longer and
postpone her court date but they need
her
to to say okay to not hold court that
day
so that they can review all of our
paperwork what the program is which
treatment center she would go to
and if they put the conservatorship
through
then basically the jailhouse would
coordinate
the transportation directly from jail to
treatment and so
amanda said yes she could have made our
job extremely difficult
and um she was actually she seemed very
like she had something to look forward
to yes and yesterday she confirmed what
lima is saying
she said on the phone call she said i'm
so glad i called you today she said you
really have a good rehab for me to go to
and i said yes this lady is the real
deal you know
and she said are you sure i said yes i
she said i can't hear you i go
she can't hear me and i said yes we have
a good rehab for you to go into when you
leave there
and she says i'm so glad i called you
today and that's how she left me
yesterday she's clear-headed now yeah
she's just totally on it that's great
wonderful
thank god yeah be a long road i'm sure
there'll be some setbacks it's a journey
yes
and all that but but this is a great
start yes
so lima came out of nowhere she did what
a blessing
i see out of the sky thank you larry
yes thank you guys thank you very much
thank you wonderful
thank you mark
you